peru's political opposition is making
another attempt to oust president pedro
castillo he's been in office less than
eight months but opponents are trying
again to impeach him despite a failed
motion in december they're now feeling
confident
76 votes is more than we expected a good
sign a good start of the will of
legislators
but it may not be easy
to remove castillo from office the
political opposition needs 87 votes and
for that they need members of castillo's
own political party to turn against him
and for now that seems unlikely
however many peruvians are discontent 63
percent of the country disapproves of
his government overshadowed by
allegations of corruption at the highest
level including castillo himself but the
president refutes these allegations
ahead of impeachment proceedings
castillo requested to speak to lawmakers
tomorrow i'll be at the parliament the
first power of the state to tell them
what we've come to do what we're doing
and what we will do for this country
having reshuffled its cabinet four times
since taking office the government has
gone from one crisis to another
castillo's allies blame opponents for
the political instability
purpose from day one has been to bring
down castillo all roads lead to the
impeachment they lost the elections they
are very hurt and want to regain lost
ground
as castillo's defense or the president
himself prepared to face impeachment
proceedings in two weeks
legislators now raised to secure enough
votes to unseat him but many peruvians
angry at peru's political class say they
prefer the president and legislators
replaced
mariana sanchez
[Music]